at some point it's just insane what's
going on and what we don't talk about
is the downside of all that of how the
entrepreneurs who are
taking these bets and running these
companies are struggling and
the the statistics around this are
haunting the entrepreneurs of today in
kind of this high growth world have
60 more mental health issues in the
average public this is in america
um eight times rated bipolar six times
depression four times suicide four times
substance abuse
we are melting down as the kind of
racehorses behind these companies
yet we don't ever hear that story until
until it's a horrific headline like the
air and shorts of the world and other
folks who've even taken their own lives
when they can't handle the pressure
for the people who are listening that
don't know who you are
what's your background how did you end
up speaking to me here
yeah so i'm a i'm a pretty life for
entrepreneur um i've been in the tech
world since i was
technically 11 years old when i learned
to program you know code hack
game build computers and then my first
company i started when i was
14. so i'm now 36 so you know
two-thirds of my life almost i've been
running tech companies and it's just
been you know
it goes without saying a passion of mine
um forever
and you know kind of before it was in
vogue like it is today
um i really just had a knack for
computers an interest in being a
self-starter
and being an entrepreneur even though i
really didn't know that's what i was for
a lot of that time
and um you know that journey led to
a number of tough lessons you know a lot
of early failures
all the stuff that you generally hear
about people go through a lifetime of
entrepreneurship
and then when i was 26 so 10 years ago
i was in chicago and um was kind of down
on my
on my luck it was not a great time
personally and professionally
um it was in the midst of the recession
you know globally but obviously you know
a lot of that was happening here in the
us
uh i was out of work my parents were out
of work um
the family wasn't doing great and i was
not really
uh you know present with a lot of
options on what to do to kind of get my
life back in order
and in the way i saw it i could either
continue to persist
trying to make something work that i
could self-generate or
go get a job and probably work some
crappy role for a number of years and
try to you know get out of debt and
those kind of things
so of course i did the entrepreneurial
thing and i created a company called
octa
and um you know for those of
the listeners that might know a company
called ideo that's the best way to
describe
octa is that we were an innovation and
design consultancy and
and companies like id have been around
for decades and they've been helping
everybody in the world design
and innovate on amazing stuff and i kind
of figured there's a room
in the market for a pure play digital
version of that
because the ideos of the world were all
kind of old industrial designers and
print designers who had kind of moved to
digital
somewhat begrudgingly and i figured if
we had a team of kind of thrifty digital
only
innovation folks that we could succeed
in that market
and that's what we did um created the
company in 2010
uh bootstrapped no investors no partners
no investors
no anything i mean no board no mentors
like truly a one-man band
and just kind of right place right time
a lot of luck perseverance
you know good fortune grinding and two
years later it was the single fastest
growing
uh innovation in ux agency in america uh
one of the fastest growing companies of
any kind in america
um two years after that we had acquired
companies we were growing
nationally and internationally um we
were
doing work for incredible companies you
know our clients were
bmw and united airlines and others um
and ultimately um it was
the epitome of that entrepreneurial
success story kind of that just like
grind it out till it works kind of thing
and then you know we're making money i'm
i'm doing ted talks and being
photographed for magazine covers it was
kind of this
very glamorous success story on one side
and the other side is is what no one
knew what was going on which is
also a classic story that i was really
struggling
personally i didn't know how to handle
the risk and stress and pressure
that i was enduring i didn't have a lot
of healthy
mechanisms for any kind of support and
and i started to struggle i mean at
a at a worse and worse level throughout
those
uh those years um really deep kind of
mental illness and mental
uh episodes of depression anxiety those
kind of things as i was dealing with
the company um it then turned into a
life of kind of excess and partying and
substance abuse and all the things that
kind of come along with
trying to balance out this incredibly
kind of ferocious lifestyle
and so in our fourth year um it all
it all collided with itself and that
took the form of a pretty severe
mental breakdown i ended up in the
hospital suffered disassociative amnesia
didn't know who or
who i was where i was had no
recollection of any part of my life
couldn't tell you my own name
and was in a hospital in that state for
a number of days um they weren't sure if
i would come back
if what state i'd be in if my brain
would ever fully recover it was a very
scary
time in my life and this is all still
when the company is you know quote
unquote crushing it
in the public world and um and uh
no one knew except one person at the
company my parents didn't know my
siblings didn't know
no one knew i hid it from everybody got
back to work whenever i was released
from the hospital and
it changed my perspective on what was
important because i kind of realized
that i was literally trading
my life and safety insanity for this
business which is
a ridiculous thing to do and so i said
we we have to end of this before it ends
and um i went and hired investment bank
we ran a managed auction
and very fortunately sold that business
outright
to salesforce i was the biggest company
in san francisco
about about a a little under a year
after that whole episode
and um obviously a very fortuitous exit
it was the best case you know best
result i could have ever asked for
given how bad the journey had gone for
me personally but how good it had gone
for the company
and it really just changed my
perspective on everything it changed how
i think about success
of what is success it changes how i
think about um
what you know what risk is is worth
risking and what parts of our lives we
should be
betting on and trading for that chance
at success
um it's changed my perception on what
matters in life going forward it was a
pretty
wild journey that all happened five
years ago and so in the last five years
i
i've actually been on your side of the
world chris i lived in london for half
the year
each year and then in greece the other
half of the year so i was doing very
little except enjoying life and just
trying to reset after what i had endured
and
ultimately you know trying to reframe
what it all meant
and um the way i found to do that was to
write
a book about it and so the book that you
previously referenced it's called a
practical way
to get rich and die trying is my memoir
and it's everything i just shared in
excruciating
detail maybe maybe too much detail in
some parts
but i wanted to get across the real
story
that we we don't often talk about people
are are rightfully
afraid to talk about um and i'm in a
position now where i can do it and i can
facilitate more of that and so that was
the point of the book and
it came out a little over a month ago
now and it's been going great so it's
it's exciting yeah what a journey man
congratulations it really it really
sounds like you're in a significantly
better more awakened more aligned
position than you were to say the least
yes it's uh you know it's um
it's difficult to describe how different
because you know i think that there's
this
this this ill-conceived notion that we
change as people i don't believe that's
true at all and most
most people smarter than me don't
believe it either is that but we can
what what can change is our mindset our
priorities those kind of things i was
always the same person
i just had totally lost the sense of
what matters and what's worth it and
what risk is
and how to manage myself and so i've
done a
excruciating amount of work in the last
five years to recover from all of that
you know mostly mentally but also
physically um but yes
it is a very different place and mindset
today thankfully
yeah very thankfully i don't know how
much longer you would have been able to
keep going like that
why do you think so obviously you're
talking about this incredible success
that you had with your company
very very fast growing in you know i
mean 2010
the early 2010s that period
was i would imagine incredibly
competitive for tech companies
um perhaps even more so than now in that
a lot of the low hanging fruit and a lot
of that first mover advantage
has probably gone from back then so
why do you think that you had any
success in business you mentioned about
work rate and timing and stuff can you
dig into that a little bit
definitely so the one thing that we did
that was most intelligent that we did
not realize we were doing
um was being a support structure to
that tailwind that you're talking about
you know the this is the era when
all of these now billion dollar tech
companies were coming out the uber is
the world everybody else
um and we were designed to be an agency
for those companies so we were here to
help them
design beautiful products to understand
their customers better to innovate
etc and so our entire set
of clients at the beginning of octa were
other startups
and so they were normally pretty well
funded they normally needed a lot of
help they couldn't hire fast enough they
could have the disciplines that we did
so we were a support structure to that
movement and so
we supplemented it instead of getting
caught in the competitive wave which was
for two it is i i i will not pretend to
say that with some man
you know some grand plan that we had
concocted that's just the way it worked
and but the second thing is is that i
mean it's funny i actually have the
apple presentation on in my other
monitor here because they're they're
they just debuted the 5g
iphone um but apple had done us a
tremendous favor and that was releasing
the iphone
and then the ipad right in that
generation and what apple did because
the iphone was 2007 and so we had come
off a couple years of being
introduced to what great digital design
is
because until the iphone we had our
blackberries and we had our palm pilots
and we had our microsoft devices
and they were perfectly usable there was
nothing wrong with any of the devices
and they did
functionally what we all need a device
to do at the time it could send a text
message and an email you could surf the
web you could listen to music
it did not you know the iphone did not
actually perform a single function
that those phones did not perform what
apple did and what they continue to do
and what they're doing as we speak in
this other monitor
is to understand us their customers
frankly better than we understand
ourselves
and they have an incredible ability to
kind of crystal ball
into the future of market needs but also
into our psyches
and they understand our behaviors our
media consumption patterns
way better than we do and if you
remember when the ipad was debuted in
2011 everyone made fun of it they're
like why do we need this
big [ __ ] iphone right like and there
was like these memes people holding the
ipad to their head like it was a joke
and and now it's you know it's
revolutionized the industry and change
everything and so
apple this is their ability this is why
they're a trillion now a multi-trillion
dollar company this is their
their magic and companies a lot of
companies started to realize that if
they could do some of that if they could
lead with design and innovation and use
your experience and user needs and
heuristics and all of those aspects
they could also create a competitive
advantage like apple and so that's what
we basically did
we would go to companies and we would
say hiring us or hiring octa
is kind of like if you could hire apple
to build your
product for you which you know you can't
do but if you could that's kind of like
hiring us
and so we had this tailwind in two
capacities that was the huge
kind of coming out of the recession you
know tech up into the right
venture back tailwind and also the
design tailwind
and again no grand plan that was that
was a lot of luck in happenstance
um but it worked for us perfectly and it
positioned us to to become what we were
how about you what made you the person
that was able to spearhead
anything and actually get ahead of
competition desperation is where it
started
um not even being positioned
i had so few options at that point chris
i was it was pretty much like you know
at best get like a minimum wage job in
like sales for a tech company at worst
go you know potentially
you know deliver food or make coffee or
something and that's where i was and
none of
nothing is wrong with that but that was
that was my set of options you know i
had fumbled through both high school and
college
i had no resume to show i spent more of
my 20s
backpacking around the world than i did
getting you know lucrative internships
and so i didn't have a lot to stand on
and for me
if i didn't make it myself i was going
to be slogging
probably for the rest of my life to just
make paychecks and pay rent and things
and i didn't want that life and so i was
desperate i was very desperate to
to achieve success and so that was the
biggest thing because
i didn't have much else i'm not the
smartest guy in the room it wasn't the
most educated guy in the room i had only
had failed startups
i'm not even a designer and that's one
of the craziest parts like i created
what became one of the most prestigious
design agencies in america and i'm not a
damn designer
and i think that that speaks to first
the desperation but also as an
entrepreneur we are really designed to
be kind of a swiss army knight we can
kind of do anything
you know when when tasked and when we're
desperate enough and that's what it was
i
mean
i tell people all the time i would have
created any company
ever that you that could make money i
didn't care what the company was it did
not matter
i am not passionate about that company i
actually founded three companies in the
same damn day
um octa was one of three i found it on
literally the same day
and just i'd go to events and depending
on how the conversation went i'd like
give a different business card the
person that i'm
still talking to you know and so it i
just wanted to succeed and so that's why
i was the right person is that i would
do
anything to succeed at that point um and
then you know i'm also a natural born
entrepreneur meaning that i'm pretty
persuasive and i can sell and i can
motivate people and in those aspects but
that comes
way after kind of just the mindset for
success
that must have been i i just i think
back to the the period that you're
talking about the early 2010s and how
much of a golden era it was
for as you called it the up and to the
right tailwind uh and we've pretty much
had
either linear or exponential growth
however you want to say it between now
and back to then it's been 2020 has been
the first year that we've seen that blip
start to fall so yeah i really imagine
that that was
a crazy crazy roller coaster how would
you define
the culture in startups and in
silicon valley
well it's changed quite a bit and i
actually think that it's it's a pretty
don't want to use the wrong word here it
it's becoming
harder and harder to defend the culture
um in the late 90s it was the gold rush
the literal
gold rush no one knew what the hell was
going on everyone is just
hoping for the best and throwing money
at anything that breathes and just like
it was a an absolute insane asylum but
there was a few winners a lot of losers
and then it all dissolved about 10 years
later and so
you know so that was the first kind of
era and i'm not sure there was a culture
it was just the culture was chaos and
then in
you know off the back of the recession
in the era when we started octa
and when a lot of the greatest companies
today were really you know becoming
their own
um from you know even though like the
the googles and such had been around for
a while they were just
really you know kind of in amazon the
world were all really figuring out their
business model then
you also had um you know
like the um the ubers of the world the
grubhub's world the whole gig economy
that was all that era and so i would say
the culture then
was somewhat healthy you you had
big bets being made on legitimate
companies but they demanded legitimate
success
it wasn't that insane see what sticks
period like it had been 10 years prior
and people were a little bit more
cautious with their capital given that
the world had recently had a financial
collapse and so i think it was
a more responsible era and then you
started to see this success and everyone
got greedy on both sides the
entrepreneurial side of the ambassador
side
and i think that has led to the culture
of today
which is frankly it's disheartening to
me as an entrepreneur
um the the amount of disaster stories
that we're having the fire festivals and
the theranoses
and the the nicolas and all you know
it's like every week is a new company
the we works every week is a new company
that's just build on
false something either at best like you
know
false proclamations to at worst like
fallonious fraud and i think that that
stems from
a a a level of greed
on both sides right it's entrepreneurs
who are trying to kind of get to that
three comma club and it's all about
excess and and it's never about anything
that's healthy and what about growth
and then investors who are facilitating
that the soft banks of the world who
just throw billion dollar checks around
you know like they're like they're
crisps and so it's like at some point
it's just insane what's going on
and and what we don't talk about is the
downside of all that
of of what of how the entrepreneurs who
are taking these bets and running these
companies
are struggling and the the statistics
around this are
haunting i mean the entrepreneurs of
today in kind of this high-growth world
have
60 more mental health issues in the
average public this is in america
eight times rated bipolar six times
depression four times suicide four times
substance abuse
we are melting down as the kind of
racehorses behind these companies
yet we don't ever hear that story until
until it's a
a horrific headline like the air and
shorts of the world and other folks
who've even taken their own lives when
they can't handle the pressure and so
you know i think that it's it's becoming
you know somewhat toxic especially when
you look at the biggest companies and
how there's just they all have kind of
black eyes now the facebooks and the
weworks and it's like
who can win this game clean anymore and
i'm not sure
that that's a good trend nor do i know
what's where it's going to go from here
and it worries me a little bit you know
to be in this industry quite frankly
do you think that's just a function of
the returns becoming decoupled
from the value that the companies add i
mean you know
i i learned with reeves weidman who
wrote a
billion dollar loser about adam newman
and about the wework
saga that's going on i learned the other
day
the term decacon which is
a unicorn with a private valuation of 10
billion or over and briefly wework was
one of those
airbnb is one of those uh as you talk
using terminology like the three comma
club and all this sort of stuff
like in no
normal like my dad or you know
your uncle like they don't think about
monetary value in these sorts of terms
the way that silicon valley does the way
that sort of startup angel investing
world
thinks about this stuff it is so
unhinged from the reality of
pretty much everyone and the the
elephant in the room
is that it seems to me that
the only people keeping this game going
are the ones
who are there to benefit from it and
from the outside looking in you can see
a ton of businesses that could add more
value
but because we have unlimited leverage
unlimited scalability with the internet
you can use the entire world as your
potential market the upside is limitless
and the downsides are only negligible
you know all of this sort of like
silicon valley startup speak
that lens how would you say
it lends a level of consideration
and thoroughness and thought outness
to an industry which to me seems to
still be very fledgling do you think
that's fair
yeah i would say that that's more than
fair and i think the problem is is that
you have both sides facilitating this
there should be a checks and balance
kind of system somewhere
like one side should prevent this from
happening and
if if you were to ask me it should be
the fiduciary side it should be the
investors
because entrepreneurs are going to be
ambitious as you let us be right
but if these investors are like slow
down and like
how about become profitable or whatever
but instead
what they do is they they value
companies through the roof and they
entice this behavior and then they
reward it
you know you i forget how many billions
adam newman left with but it was
he's a billionaire after tanking wework
that is not a good model to speak about
you know what you should and should not
do and then you have like
i don't know if you followed nicola
which is my new favorite
company and i say that incredibly
facetiously but nicola
you know they're calling themselves
nicola because they want to be like
tesla which is just
oh didn't they claim didn't they claim
this is the truck company
yeah the iveco didn't they say they had
a partnership with iveco
eveco i'm not sure about your site so
over here it's a gm partnership and and
so what they've done
is they they debuted a truck and it's a
it's a freight truck
and it's very similar to teslas and and
i forget the
there's a certain kind of battery if it
was
whatever it was they have a certain kind
of battery patented invented
that can create the most you know
effective and efficient evs in the world
etc
they debut this truck and they have this
beautifully produced video of this truck
flying down the road and whatever
and then they received some billions in
pre-orders off the video
and then they never release the truck
and they say it's in development
development development and then a year
later they debut
a car very similar to the tesla car i
think it
i i hope it wasn't called this it may
have been called the cougar it's just
it's a horrible name
and but it's it's they they develop they
now have a a sedan coming and again
there's not a single product in the
market they now have have announced a
truck and they've announced the car
and they've announced this patent that
they hold about this
battery technology which people very
smart people like elon musk are like
yeah
that's not a thing that doesn't exist
anyway so then they
take the company public in the midst of
this tailwind
and at one point i think the company had
a valuation of like
15 or 18 billion dollars
and this is before they have shipped a
single
product or anybody's even seen a single
product
and their ceo i think his name is trevor
milton was out there doing the game and
doing the talks and it was very
you know whatever and then a short
selling firm which is hilarious
uh they put a report out um they're
actually called hindenburg research
which i thought was just brilliant
and they put they put a report out
claiming that every claim nicola has
made is false
and that the even the video of the truck
flying down the road
was actually being rolled down a hill
and they just turned the tilting of the
camera
to make it look like it was driving and
the truck never even worked
well nicola defends themselves by saying
well we never said it worked
we just showed that we have an idea for
a truck
and and then within a week there's you
know fraud allegations and trevor milton
resigns as ceo
he's kicked off the board the whole
dance fast forward a month
their valuation their market cap as we
speak right now is 9.18 billion still
and this is where i'm just like this is
where i there's just a problem
like this is a problem it's like a
company is now on the public stock
market giving
you know investor updates to to the
public
that is worth 10 billion dollars
afterwards getting caught in a
massive act of fraud that is now being
federally investigated that led to the
ceo resigning
and it's like okay there is a problem
right now and and this this stuff
worries me
so yeah i spoke to reeves about this
were you
privy to the insane uplift that was seen
when the electric scooter companies
first came out of course
i mean at least they had products but
even
that even that the market sentiment and
the valuation i remember because i was
in america at the time
and they were doubling the valuation of
lime and bird and the other ones
they were doubling every month it was
like 100 million 200 million 400 million
800 million and that was
the the period of time i was in america
like i i ventured into america and they
were worth like 100 million i left
america and they were worth 800 million
well
and this is the worrisome part it's like
is you wonder how this is facilitated
because if it's on the public market it
could be market manipulation whatever
but it's on the private market
someone is facilitating this and it's
and what's scary is that it appears to
be these investors like
the softbank is a great one to do it i
mean they looked at adam newman said how
much money do
you need he's like a billion dollars
they're like right here's 20. and it's
like wait what
like i needed one and
and then and then they're like well now
you have 20. so you better use this
to to to you know to do completely
unrealistic things and
create an unrealistic sense of scale and
growth um
and then they wonder why he creates an
unsustainable model
um and you know and so
it's no it's no uh mystery
why this is happening but it certainly
is a mystery to me that it continues to
happen
and like and this is still happening
every single day right now
it is just blows my mind is this house
of
invisible emperor clothes cards going to
come crashing down at some point
the thing is there's too much money
behind like the soft banks of the world
the reason that they're cutting these
checks
they don't know what else to do with it
you know and this is all you know
saudi wealth fund or sovereign fund
backed capital right so
there's hundreds and hundreds of
billions of dollars that they're trying
to deploy
and so well and they're and they're just
one of them and so well
those those kind of funds are out there
of
literally limitless capital they're
going to continue to make
ridiculous bets and find a way out of
them which is the craziest part like
you know when they when they kicked out
adam they brought in
you know their own i think he's a former
gp of the fund to now be the ceo wework
so
they just kind of like hyperscale let it
crash the ground put their own people in
probably take the majority of equity and
then build them up and they'll probably
have a fortuitous exit which is
which is obscene that they're gonna
actually win on that deal probably
at some point um it's happening with
uber it's happening with all these
companies and so
you know until the entire paradigm
changes
and investors actually worry about
making their money back with any kind of
practicality
it's hard to say how this will change
because who isn't going to
who's going to turn down that money and
that opportunity it's like an entire
industry that is a golden goose
in fact no it's an entire paradigm a
whole structure
where people are just able to print
money
uh i had jason kalakanis on here a
little while ago
and um i just i tried to get him to
explain to me about how angel investing
works
but i think fundamentally
because i'm a small medium sized entrep
enterprise entrepreneur
the fact that market sentiment and
valuation is completely decoupled from
what the service that the
business can actually produce for me
it's a logical step that i am unable to
take it's like i haven't had that
module loaded into my brain from the
matrix and i just can't
get how it works and then we've seen
even with companies that are operating
this year let's look at tesla
like what is it five five x odds yeah
five exits stock price way way
way above companies like nissan and ford
and i'm sure you saw these graphs about
the volume of cars that tesla produces
versus the volume of cars that ford
produces
is like the same differential as the the
stock valuation between the two of them
but in reverse
it's crazy and and this is where you
have to wonder
and again a lot of the the massive tech
bubble of 2020 right at the back of the
pandemic kicking in was softbank right
it was revealed that softbank was
actually buying all these equities to
drive these prices through the roof so
so it's kind of all part and parcel it's
all it's all working together in the
same systems but it's a it's a scary
thing and
you know i mean the fact that you can
become a billionaire by tanking a
company is
is scary and i was speaking to david
rubinstein who was the founder of the
carlisle group
so one of the most successful
businessmen in america
unequivocally he creates one of the
biggest private equity companies in the
world
he is revered amongst that world
um you know he is in the same category
as the bill gates and
those kind of folks and he lives in dc
he's highly politically connected
he's also the chairman of the
smithsonian of duke university i mean
it's like
this guy is is literally one of the
biggest power brokers in the world and
has earned it over the last
36 years of doing what he's done
he's worth 2.3 billion and i and i
look at that and i'm like so so you're
talking about the guy who tanked the
company that everyone now
hates and lost investors billions of
dollars who's now living in the hamptons
in a compound alone
is worth i think he's worth like six
billion dollars and david rubenstein who
has done everything right for 36 years
and created
true and you know and the generational
companies
and and development is worth two billion
dollars and that's what i'm just like
there's something
really really wrong here do you think
that you were overpaid for your company
when you exited
no um i i think that
unlike the businesses that we're talking
about we had
um an incredible well we carried an
incredible amount of value
in our discipline and we you know we had
incredibly high profit margins we were
bootstrapped through and through i never
took a dollar in capital
ever can you just explain what
bootstrapped means
please yes so absolutely no investors
are outside capitals so
i started the company with about eight
hundred dollars net
investment um that was on the back of a
credit card and
i used the revenue and then profit from
the first client to facilitate growth
and did that from then on
so you know you cannot all the
examples we've been giving from the you
know teslas and nicolas and the
works you can't do any of those relying
on your own profit because they don't
have any so
for us i had to run an incredibly
value-based
business with high margins and high
throughput and great cash flow
management and stuff
to do my business relative would have
failed and so you know we had an
incredible amount of value we did
extraordinary work
and salesforce um was incredibly
intelligent on
how they saw the value proposition of a
business like mine
fitting into a to their consulting group
and it was
you know fortuitous on both sides the
majority of my employees that they
acquired are still at salesforce you
know five years later
you know inside fantastic long-term
careers and
and um you know and they're also one of
the fastest growing silicon valley
stocks
since then so that's awesome man that's
proper
like legacy [ __ ]
yeah i mean listen it was a small
business by all intents you know we were
we were a small company when it when
you're compared to salesforce or even
most of the businesses they acquired
they do a lot of you know
multi-billion dollar acquisitions et
cetera et cetera um
that you know wasn't us we were a small
kind of going-on medium-sized company
but it obviously you know it was a lot
more um
i would say real than who we're talking
about it was a real business with real
cash flow and real people and
and that's what they wanted to acquire
and we're happy they did
and i think everyone is very satisfied
with how that all went down
awesome talk us through the craziest
year that you
had in business then personally what
what was going on what was the typical
day what were some of the
big incidents which occurred
yeah it was the year it was the last
year of the company that i alluded to
earlier
and it kind of you know the reason it
was so crazy is because
you know i'm managing a company that
that had just experienced 1100
organic growth for an agency this is an
agency like
you know it's one thing to scale a
software company because you can hire a
few more people but then grow
a thousand percent and it's you know
it's just scaling software
when you scale an agency you're you're
scaling human beings
who are incredibly difficult to hire
they are very expensive
and so um we had ex that was the growth
we were experiencing we were i think the
400th give or take fastest growing
company in america of any kind
and i think the the only the only
fast-running agency in that caliber of
our
of our type in our specific niche and um
so things are going well and and i am in
a position where i am
being recognized for that success i am
being asked to do interviews and
ted talks and i'm on magazine covers and
this is a new world for me i have never
experienced
anything like that and people care about
who you are and what you're up to and
you you're
invited to all kinds of crazy stuff you
have a seat at the table with you know
the
the governors and it's it's that world
and and all of a sudden you're then
making money
i became a millionaire the day before i
turned 30.
and you know i had this stretch goal as
a teenager of being a millionaire by 30.
and i literally got there the day before
i turned 30.
um and that's not even like uh that's
not being positioned literally my last
day being 29 i became later
and so from all of that things were
going very well and it was a bit surreal
it was going
so well but at the same time this is
when personally i was struggling
more and more and more and more and more
and so you have these diametrically
opposed
kind of positions where as one side the
kind of public side if you will is a
going about as well as it can and then
seemingly just continuing to get better
everything people can't see which is
systematically getting worse and worse
and worse and worse and worse
and you know no one knew i was dealing
with lawsuits from
other you know from an old business
partner no one knew that you know i was
battling every day to you know to win
certain accounts that if we had not got
or we had lost certain clients we could
have you know
had a down year or whatever um no one
knew i was dealing with the mental
health issues that i was no one knew
that i was
you know escaping to you know las vegas
or another degenerate playground you
know three times a month
and and having very bad behavior because
that's what
that's what allowed me to stop thinking
about all my issues for
a day or two and so it was you know
and and work was so busy it was like it
was almost being managed to the minute
i remember i'd have you know my
assistant would be like you have a call
i'm going to start it at 9
16 and at 9 22 i'm going to grab you so
you can go do this it was like that was
my day
and it you know it was just it was
truly crazy insofar as there was
incredible parts there were
very dire parts and it was
such it was where i always wanted to be
i was succeeding for the first time ever
but it didn't really feel like it
because
there was all this other stuff i was
dealing with and so that was a truly
truly crazy year i mean we i don't know
how many people we hired that year were
opening up offices in london and then in
the west coast and we
um god we opened up a
massive gorgeous office in chicago that
we designed like i designed every
square into that place it was just
incredible we had signed all of our
major
accounts like the bmws of the world we'd
you know design the interior of one of
their cars like
crazy stuff so that was that was the
coolest period of my life ever well also
being the worst
[Laughter]
which i think is entrepreneurship in a
nutshell oh absolutely so
here's something that i learned from ben
bergeron's chasing excellence
which is that when we look back on a lot
of the experiences that we have in life
especially to do with sort of business
and discomfort and stuff like that
we don't ever look back and find any
glory or really any interest
in the times when things were easy what
we find
as the real exciting times is oh do you
remember when
we had to pull three all nighters in a
row to get the project finished
and we ordered dominoes and you slept
under the desk and this this and
like every you know even the people
listening who aren't an entrepreneur you
can remember
um completing an assignment for school
or college or something
and you you had to pull you had to get a
case of red bull in and you and your
friends didn't leave the library for
three days
you know that's where the glory is
associated with it but
obviously the goal of that or the
um yeah the proposed the best outcome of
that
is to avoid going completely
broke in one way or another broke
physically broke
spiritually broke mentally broke
financially you know broke to jail
like uh judicially yeah it's
it's yeah you're spot on with that and i
resonate with that a lot
because when i think back of my journey
i rarely think about
the quote-unquote great times like what
comes my mind first
is not the money not like the the day i
became a millionaire
i barely recall it i i saw my bank
account i was like oh
a million dollars and i called my mom to
tell her and she's like nice john like
no one gave a [ __ ] it was very
uneventful even though that was a
somewhat
i don't know that was a that should have
been i think a memorable day or maybe
israel it's
a big milestone yeah if you think so
except
it was highly forgetful you know
forgettable for me
compared to some of the tragic [ __ ] up
times that we had and
there's this quote by my favorite author
chuck palahniuk and he says
it's so hard to forget pain but it's
even harder to remember
sweetness we have no scars to show for
happiness we learn so little from peace
and i think that that really speaks to
entrepreneurship in a big way
is that we we actually in in those times
where things were just great and things
are happy you don't
learn a lot you're not really
progressing it really is those
battles that you hopefully win when when
you really are in the best
position you can be in what are some of
the
lowest points that you can remember from
that year
well the mental breakdown is pretty low
that was
that was were you in the office was that
a weekend in las vegas that was highly
inappropriate
that is also detailed in the first
chapter it's the intro it's the intro to
the book yeah exactly
the intro to the book so i came back
from a from a bad behavior weekend
and you know anybody who's had that kind
of weekend knows that you're in a
fragile state to say the least and
i proceeded to attempt to continue the
weekend
and so you know i come straight back
from a weekend of partying to throw a
party at my house and i had this
ridiculous
penthouse high-rise in chicago and
it was towards the end of that most
people had left and i was there with a
woman and we were
you know kind of getting ready to wind
down and the la the best i can recall
and a little bit this has been filled in
by by her actually later on but
from what i recalled everything just
kind of got
kind of matrixy like i i kind of lost a
sense of reality and the world kind of
started like it's kind of folding in on
me
like a little inception kind of
perspective and
and um and the last thing i was able to
do is open my phone and call
kevin who was my ceo at the company and
and as i
as it was ringing i blacked out and
according to her i just
felt like in the movies just straight
faint forward slam my head on the ground
and she called 911 and um and i woke up
in the hospital
my co i consciously woke up in the
hospital three days later
now i had been awake in the meantime but
i had no no memory of that
i was in a completely disassociative
state which is not a place you want to
be uh
and so um it was a it was a horrific
time and it was the first time i'd ever
really confronted my own
existence my own humanity um you know
there was a there was a
better than you know and nil
zero chance that i was never going to
recover from that fully
and they didn't know what that meant it
could have been severe um
brain damage it could have been severe
memory loss
some of which i do have it could have
been all it could have been a stroke
they weren't sure at first you know it
was it was a horrific
thing to consider you know that you
almost died at age 30
after all this quote unquote success and
it was awful it was
really awful what did they diagnose as
the
contribution to that obviously a bunch
of substances and a high heart rate and
a lack of sleep is
going to contribute to that but is it
chronic long-term stress is it something
else
yeah it's all of the above and and
effectively
it's like a damn breaking in your brain
at some point you just
you just put too much you know
volatility too much
um you know just pressure
and you're it's actually kind of
fascinating like it wasn't at the time
but but in reflection when it was
explained to me
your brain it's kind of a defense
mechanism so your brain is like you know
what
this isn't going well and and this
and we're kind of you know we're feeling
the damage of all of this and so we're
going to kind of just like
hit the reset and and this is why it's
called dissociative amnesia because when
you disassociate
you're having a personality fugue state
and so your
your brain's kind of like this this
current state is damaging us so we're
just going to kind of put that off the
side and
almost start anew and that's why you
know
a person in my state i didn't know my
own name didn't know what city i was in
i knew what a name
was i knew what a city was i could list
10 cities i just didn't have a clue
which one mine was because i was
literally a new identity
for a few days and that was the brain's
way
of forcing me to stop which is
somewhat incredible that your brain can
do so also
horrific to experience that is
so crazy yeah and you'll see it
you know i've obviously done quite a bit
of research and so if you research like
fugue states
if you research disassociated amnesia
you can read you know
and it's all off the back of a mental
break of some kind you know and
and for me it was a psychotic break
meaning i was suffering psychosis and so
for the weeks leading up to it
the one time i remember clearly which is
always weird to talk about is
i was watching television in my living
room for some period of time i don't
know if it was an hour or two hours just
kind of honestly doing what we do and
watching television
and then i realized the tv was off and
had been the entire time
and i kind of was like that is not good
you know like
and then you're like did i turn it off
and you realize it was never on i
like i i was staring at a blank
television thinking i was watching tv
for hours
and it's then those things had happened
and normally before a psychotic break
you have these moments of psychosis as
you lead up to it so there usually is
some indicators
we generally don't notice them because
it's just kind of like
it's so surreal but what i reflected on
is i was like yeah there were a few
warning signs weren't there
so looking back obviously we can
armchair philosophize
about the the beauty of the newly
awakened
36 years old understanding aligned
john rower but would
he would the person sat in that chair
today
have been able to do what was needed 10
years ago
yes and no um if somebody had given me a
crystal ball
and they had said as you start this
company
here's what where you'll be in five
years you'll be
a rich man who almost died
and you'll be pretty screwed up from the
whole thing but you will have
technically succeeded
that would have obviously been shocking
but i don't think i would have had the
wherewithal to not
to do anything different i still don't
know if i had just known the result
what i possibly would have done
different and the reason i say that and
this is kind of a weird thing that
people don't always expect i would say
is because it worked so had i changed
anything like for instance i was dating
this wonderful woman named courtney when
the
when the whole company started i broke
up with her in the second year
because i convinced myself that i could
not be
a good partner and and give attention to
somebody
while being a great entrepreneur and ceo
i said there's not enough bandwidth to
do both
so i'm going to choose being an
entrepreneur and i now realize that's
ridiculous that's hogwash like you you
can there's a lot of people who not only
are
great partners in the process but they
attribute their success to that partner
and so but with that said if i were to
to go back and let's say i could do it
all again but this time
instead of becoming a degenerate i
stayed with my lovely girlfriend
and and used that as an anchor maybe i
wouldn't have worked as hard
maybe i would have been distracted so
it's so i can't reasonably
say that there are things that i would
actually change because i don't know
what the result would have been
um looking forward which is all we can
really do
if i was to start a company right now
obviously i would do
everything differently the first would
be not to bet my entire life in
existence on a damn tech company
but secondly which is ways to to be
mentally you know
acute you know ways to um stay attuned
to your you know
your mind and body throughout the entire
journey to find some methods of support
to have a good structure around you to
be honest what you're dealing with to
seek therapy i would do all those things
now and that but that's looking forward
it's very difficult to say
with looking back because at the end of
the day it worked who am i to say that i
should have done it differently
if it worked so it's a weird kind of
place to
to reflect from i understand you think
the ends justified the means by that
logic a little bit and again this is
where
it's hard to admit that because you know
i had some pretty bad behavior and i'm
not proud of a lot of what i did and
and it was a pretty wild few years i
wasn't a very good son or brother or a
friend of people and so like
it's not that it justifies it but at the
same time
if you were going to go redo it wouldn't
you want the same result and so it's
kind of hard to say like
you know i would have i would have been
a better friend
um but i would happily have you know
gone bankrupt it's like
yeah probably not you know like so it's
it's hard
it's very difficult to reflect on it
from that way and that's why
for folks who who have read the book or
are going to read the book
i worked very hard while writing it to
not
judge i didn't want to say like oh i
wish i hadn't done this or i still
regret this or
man look how brilliant i was it's all
just what happened it's
just a story that we can now look back
on for some high level indicators
but it's not a practical no pun intended
it's not a practical
guide for what to do or what not to do
yeah
i think that's a really um
reassuringly unique viewpoint
a stance that you've taken that very
often it would be easy for someone to
polarize their opinion for it to be yeah
it was absolutely worth it or no
i i definitely wouldn't have done it
that way i would have totally changed
things around
um i think that it's very reassuring to
know that there's someone who's prepared
to sort of go to that uncomfortable
place of truth uh and and also to
deliver it with a little bit of subtlety
and nuance
i think that is interesting just to
bookend the
girlfriend discussion we've spoken about
this on the show before
do you think on balance that more
entrepreneurs
are successful with or without partners
if you take a normal distribution of
entrepreneurs
more are successful with partners for
sure based on
based on stories i've heard
conversations that i've had people are
more successful with partners
why do you think um and i think well i
think it's it's quite obvious i think it
creates
assuming the relationship is healthy
right i think that you know people can
find themselves in somewhat toxic
relationships
in those journeys because it can feel
comforting at first it's kind of
disguised comfort
but i think if you're in a secure
healthy relationship you have an
automatic support system which is
something we
normally lack as entrepreneurs as any
kind of support system much less one who
you're literally with every day
it forces you to not isolate which is a
very common you know characteristic of
entrepreneurs we lock ourselves in a
room and hope for the best
if you're with somebody they're not
going to let you do that likely at least
not constantly and so you're going to be
pulled out of your element and forced to
talk and forced to to realize there's
more going on than your little
tech company and i think that there's
going to be a sense of compassion that
you forget people will have for you
one thing that i i experience in my
journey and i've heard a lot from
entrepreneurs
is that we kind of find ourselves in
this like um
like a shame spiral kind of environment
where we're shameful for what we're
doing and how we're spending our time
and we don't want to admit
decisions that we've made and so that's
where a lot of that inner turmoil comes
from and i think if somebody's saying to
you
you know listen i understand you a lot
of hard decisions to make and it's okay
and i you know i would do the same thing
even as silly as it sounds just hearing
that would have done a lot for me and i
know for other people so
um so yeah i i think you know again i
can't call it a rule i can't tell
somebody who's like
if there's some single entrepreneur i
can't be like go find it find yourself a
relationship
and then find you know that that's
ridiculous but i can say off
a lot of discussions with incredibly
successful people
that is more often than not a key
that's really interesting i think i
think that you are correct with that as
well
i i know my experience as an
entrepreneur for 14 years
that the rumination and the amount of
time that you spend inside of your own
head
i mean what think about what you were
doing you said it before why were you
going to vegas why were you partying
hard
it was in an effort to force yourself
out of that head
and you know even stuff even stupid
things like owning a dog
you know like if you own a dog you have
to project
that you you dissolve your sense of
self-importance
because there is something else and it's
beholden to you
you need to look after it right so i
think that is a
that's a really really interesting
insight so okay we've had this
we've had this crazy career we've done
also the learning and the reflection
hopefully sufficient time for you to be
able to at least begin to normalize what
it was that you went through
what are the high level lessons what can
we take away from it and try and
implement into our own lives or avoid or
strategies and everything honestly this
is going to sound
this is a horribly answered question but
i don't really have too many and the
reason is is because
going back to the earlier point that you
made it kind of that nuance is
i made a lot of mistakes and so for me
to try to tell people what they should
do or what the lessons are i think is
ridiculous like
you know and it's i hate that successful
people
believe that they have more sense of
what is good and bad right and wrong
the right or growing ways do things than
other people do because we generally
have our
our timeline right and so i can speak to
some personal things that i've
experienced but they don't translate
into blanket
advice or lessons or any of those things
because
if i if if i speak to an individual
chris and i
if we're having a pint in london and
you're saying hey here's my situation
can you give me some advice based on
yours i'd happily do so
but i'm speaking to a room of
entrepreneurs i say here's three things
you should do
maybe five percent of those that could
be perfect for 80 of it's relevant and
15
i'm going to damage by them following my
advice because
everyone is so different and so you know
my lessons are
purely my experience that's why i wrote
the book how i wrote it it was very
purposeful to not
have takeaways to not have lessons to
not have advice it's just
here's what happened and based on who
you are and who every reader is
they're going to take away their own
anecdotes from them
i think again man i'm i'm really really
impressed with
the five steps to
10x your business like the you know
so much well everyone that's listening
will know that i have
very strong opinions about gary vee and
about grant cardone and about this like
hustle pawn a kind of success by any
means mentality that we have going on at
the moment
and again like we spoke at the beginning
about the fact that the emperor kind of
does have no clothes with regards to
company valuations in silicon valley
i think that there is an intellectual
cerebral equivalent which is going on
within motivation and success gurus at
the moment as well
we could talk another hour about this
topic um it it
i actually think that that movement
is quite dangerous um
and i think that it's probably not too
dissimilar to the startups we talked
about earlier this quest for
you know for financial success and
whatever else is is driving a paradigm
that is literally toxic and dangerous to
people who are listening and who are
taking it quite seriously because again
you speak to a room of 2000 people who
are struggling to find their kind of
avenue forward there's no such thing as
blanket advice there's literally no such
thing and
and it's not just advice that point it's
it's a sometimes cultish kind of level
following
and i struggle with it a lot and i talk
out against it and i actually did in the
book i think i was
um i won't i won't repeat the line but i
i'm quite forward about my thoughts on
the topic and so yeah
and that's why i try to do the exact
opposite you know i i only know what i
know i've had one experience in my life
which is my life i've had one timeline
done some things right and things wrong
i'll continue to make mistakes i'll
continue to do stupid things
but at the end of the day you know i i
would embrace all of that and it would
be very foolish of me to try to cast
any of that down as some you know unjust
wisdom to somebody else
you are aware that that's a much more
subtle approach though and that
in a world where absolutes and
polarization is what seduces a lot of
people
that you are potentially sacrificing
clout and status and
and notoriety for this particular
message
sure um you know the nice part about
being where i am and i apologize because
i have to jump for another podcast here
in a second
but uh the um i'd love to continue
as well as at some point if you want to
do a second part of this but you know
one of the things
that i'm very fortunate to to have is i
don't have the need for clout and
and and you know these kind of things
like you know
if i was worried about people loving me
i wouldn't have written the book i wrote
because no one looks worse in this book
than me
and so i'm not exactly on a quest for
you know
let's say this is not an ego play to say
the least and so
i don't need to try to say the same
thing everyone else is to get more you
know people re
quoting me or some something stupid i i
believe in what i believe in
people who care to hear that and have
that nuance will hear it you know uh
from me and those who need to be they
can you know
walk over coals and that's going to make
them good at business can go do that
so dude i love it i really really enjoy
a much more subtle and nuanced approach
to this this sort of messaging
hopefully is what we're going to see
coming out of silicon valley more over
the
over the next decade so a practical way
to get rich and die trining
a memoir about risking it all will be
linked in the show notes below
anywhere else that people should go and
check out john
yeah uh my social is just john roa my
name on instagram and twitter don't use
facebook
um and uh the book is available at all
booksellers i think across
europe as well as here in america and
then um
i have a podcast it's currently called
the genre show we're actually
relaunching it with a really cool pivot
in the next couple weeks here so you can
currently follow the john roach show and
then when it pivots you'll then have
that feed
um but yeah and that's that's the so
chris i appreciate your time
amazing thank you so much
[Music]